[Musique]
isabelle carré corinne masiero béatrice
dalle ou najat vallaud belkacem 343
femmes des artistes des politiques des
féministes qui s'engage une nouvelle
fois pour l'avortement
douze semaines le délai aujourd'hui 12
semaines et nous proposons de le passer
à 14 semaines
je pense que c'est à notre portée que
par le manceau n'aurait de faire à
l'occasion de cet anniversaire
ce pas ce progrès tiens vous alerter que
la ville de poitiers ne compte pas
soutenir le sport motorisé
nous allons donc pour cette année voté
une subvention à hauteur de 4000 euros
le club honfleurais en 1924 à doc a pris
par courriel que la ville allait
supprimer sa subvention et pas compris
on n'est pas des pollueurs entre
guillemets vu que alors c'est vrai on a
besoin d'un avion à moteur pour décoller
ça fait quinze minutes de vol moteur et
après on peut voler trois heures quatre
heures sans rien consommer juste avec
des courants d'air la maire de poitiers
a justifié sa décision
je pense que vous vous rendez pas compte
aujourd'hui 2 des rêves en fait auquel
on doive des rêves dont on doit
préserver les enfants en fait fin les
rien c'est triste mais ne va plus faire
partie des rêves d'enfants aujourd'hui
on pourrait faire un best-of de toutes
les décisions sectaires des mers europe
ecologie les verts entre fêter noël
célébrée en arbre mort entre non il faut
pas que les enfants rêvent de ça donc on
va mettre une machine pour contrôler les
rêves des enfants maintenant franchement
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont voté ee lv aux précédentes
municipales qui sont demandées doit
aujourd'hui puisque c est absolument
catastrophique ce que nous montre et
maire écologiste aujourd'hui comme comme
vision du monde si on triste austère
c'est une folie qui est révoltante parce
qu'on entendra responsables politiques
dire qu'il faut changer les rêves des
enfants
ça m'inquiète au plus profond de
moi-même je n'ai aucune envie que la
maire de poitiers nient que quelques
responsables politiques que ce soit
n'est certainement pas les verts les
plus radicaux change les rêves de mes
enfants
on a la mer de poitiers qui explique aux
enfants qui ne doivent plus rêver
d'avion et à une semaine on avait la
maire de strasbourg qui finançait dans
le cas de la construction d'une mosquée
une fédération qui avait salué un
gouvernement
interrompue sur cette espèce de nez au
jansénisme de ses lacets la mauvaise
écologie je vous parler d'environnement
l'instant il ya là clairement la bonne
jansénisme écologique oui c'est vega
yahia la bonne et la mauvaise écologie
c'est très clair l'imaginaire des
enfants qui naissent aujourd'hui ne sera
pas le même que l'imaginaire des enfants
qui sont nés au début du 20e siècle par
exemple qui accuse marqué par
l'imaginaire de l'aérien ou conquérant
on va dire et c'est un super imaginaire
aujourd'hui ça doit changer et je pense
qu'on peut faire rêver les enfants
autrement
monsieur djebbari il est quoi il est
ministre des transports mais c'est aussi
le lobby de l'aérien au sein du
gouvernement toute sa carrière il l'a
fait dans l'aérien marie lot à ses
créateurs voilà on parle il paraît alors
la donne en cubes ration autoritaire est
moribonde voilà on parle dans cette
affaire de subventions qui sont donnés
je crois si j'ai bien suivi vous allez
me corriger c'est pas le cas à une
association qui fait les baptêmes de
l'air pour les personnes en situation de
handicap pour les plus étonnants les
gardiens il faut qu'ils rêvent d'aller
dans les airs et s'ils pouvaient rêver
d'aller dans les airs autrement qu'avec
du pétrole et imaginer les solutions de
demain pour le faire alors tout le monde
s'en portera bien entendre qu' un enfant
n'aurait plus le droit de rêver de voler
je trouve ça extrêmement choquant a je
comprends pas qu'un responsable
politique puisse dire ça est-ce que vous
n'assumez pas voilà sur l'avion si vous
deviez vous donne est en train de
changer d'époque de changer de
priorisation quoi est-ce que vous
n'assumez pas ça mais j'assume
parfaitement ça j'assume parfaitement
que dans une ville on dise je préfère
mettre l'argent pour des enfants qui ne
peuvent pas partir en vacances que pour
1% du budget d'un aéroclub bernard tapie
et son épouse ont donc été cambriolé la
nuit dernière à leur domicile de
combs-la-ville en seine-et-marne une
opération violente puisque l'homme
d'affaires de 78 ans et sa femme ont été
attachées et frappé par leur agresseur
quand on sait et c'est de notoriété
publique que bernard tapie est malade et
qu'il est souffrant je trouve que c'est
particulièrement abject de le cambrioler
de le ligoter de le molester où c'est
que c'est des faits qui sont graves qui
sont particulièrement bouleversant nous
je veux leur dire mon soutien et ma
solidarité